girls
i'm sorry this is how it is this is how
it's going to work like it or not okay
it's not about being better or or who's
better or who it's just
islam divided responsibilities
you can't have two captains in one ship
the ship's gonna sink
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
that's crazy because y'all know how like
impactful it was yeah isn't it if you're
wasn't this it was so
it was such a strong dream
that i woke up
and then i was talking to my dad and i
was crying
because i was strong the dream was how
impactful the dream was
and then i ended up driving to uh the
mosque it was like 5 40 something
to do fajr at the mosque and i was
crying the entire way to the mosque
and subhanallah i think it's crazy that
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the dunya the three muslims podcast
today we're joined with a very special
guest
good to be here guys the four muslims
it's good to have you it's good to have
you so why don't you tell the viewers a
little bit about yourself you know they
might have seen you on tiktok or around
so why don't you give a brief
introduction about yourself
alhamdulillah
well i i started my my journey in islam
maybe more than 10 years ago
i wasn't really that into islam i was
very ignorant about it i was just muslim
by name just like
you know some some people and
and i was always fascinated and always
curious about my religion and my
identity as a muslim
and so this really bothered me because
what i was doing really contradicted
with the way i was living was really
contradictory with with what i believed
and what a muslim is i had a you know i
had a vague idea and so i started my
journey reading and watching youtube
youtube
youtube videos of debates and things
like that because that was entertaining
and so i started with that and slowly
slowly my my love and appreciation and
respect
to my religion and my identity grew
gradually video after video
you know reminder after reminder
then i i moved on to books
and from books i moved on to uh
which is of course the circle of
knowledge you know i go to to mosques
and i meet people and i meet chicks and
and one thing led to another and
slowly i started growing within these
these ten years
and one day my friend was like you know
you speak really good english why don't
you just start filming and talking about
whatever knowledge you collected
throughout these these ten years or so
so i said yeah why not i mean why why
don't we ask our chefs
because i had a couple of shares and
what we call the mentors basically so i
said what do you guys think well should
i should i do this they're like yeah
absolutely there's there's a big gap in
in the western or the english speaking
uh
community or dawa
dabwa field so why don't you do that i
said all right fine so i started filming
and it was it was awful it was really
bad
i got no likes it was just me watching
it and my friends
and just one day because we we had it
was new to me and one day i casually
just picked up the phone and said blah
blah blah blah blah really casually and
i cracked a joke and that spread
everywhere
it went viral
and from then on here i am
i'm on tick tock and i'm on instagram
just trying to share what knowledge i
have
i'm not a chef of course but i'm just a
brother who whatever i've learned in
these 10 years whatever i've read and
understood from our ulama from our
meshair i just pass on uh to the younger
generation
because i i say it in a simple way maybe
not in the classical ulama way and the
sharia
linguistics and the words that they use
because that's too heavy maybe on on the
younger generation
and so i started doing that
alhamdulillah things are going well so
far
so that's my story on
in social media
it's a wonderful story and uh i feel
like a lot of our viewers can relate to
that um and that being said a lot of uh
episodes we've done so far have been on
marriage so we're going to continue that
inshallah today and that's what today's
episode is going to be about uh before
we go in i have a simple question for
you or it might not be so simple so when
people come into islam and they learn
about islamic marriages it's easy to see
it as something very measurable right
there's it's an agreement it's a
contract there's rights and
responsibilities uh a lot of people in
the west namely kofad they also look at
long-term relationships you know a lot
of them the youth might not get married
today uh in non-muslim sphere they look
at it as something you know equal and
unconditional and it's like a
partnership so
how would you look at this aspect would
you look at it as something you know the
former or like the latter
all right first of all i have to say
this i'm i'm married
from also more than more than 10 years
now got four kids
marriage in islam goes both ways
it is something that's romantic it is
something that
it's built it's the infrastructure of
marriage in islam is built on
built on
mercy built on tolerance built on love
built on all these things if you don't
have that you're not going to have a
marriage that's the first part the
second part is
is it's built on rules and
responsibilities
it's built on something that's
quantifiable it's built on
on what are my roles as as a husband and
what are my roles as a wife and you have
to identify these things
and it's just it's not just going out
for pizza or going out to the movies or
whatever you guys want to want to call
it or describe it in marriage it's not
like what the movies are showing you
and this is a very very dangerous and
distorted
image and concept of marriage people are
so
into these romantic uh relationships
when it comes to marriage and they
forget the big part the big elephant in
the room which is your responsibilities
things that are measurable just like you
mentioned
what about the house what about the
budget what about your work what about
your responsibilities at home who's
gonna clean up who's going to look after
the kids who's going to pay the bills
these things are serious if that
doesn't work
you're going to hurt your love you're
going to hurt the infrastructure you're
going to hurt your tolerance with your
wife you're going to hurt your your
mercy with your wife your wife or your
husband your partner basically so i
think i think it's it's extreme and we
see this
in the life of the prophet
we see this in the quran we see this in
the sunnah
the
prophetic when when when he
when the first revelation came to him
who did he run to to his friends
to
he went to khadija
his wife
that's the first person you come to so
your wife is your friend
your wife is your partner your wife is
your lover your wife is everything to
you and your husband is also everything
to you you go back to them that's the
first person you got to think about
whenever there's a problem when there
whenever there's a celebration whenever
there's a
confusion whenever there is anything you
go to your wife because she's a part of
you and you're a part of her
so i think it's both ways really
alhamdulillah
okay that's a that's a very fair answer
i know you have anything to say to me
what if what if the man has four wives
does he go to each one
wow you you're going strong at the
beginning
i'm just curious about it
if someone has four wives what do you
mean it with regards to the question
that that you just
like if something were to go wrong like
would would they go to all four of them
and he goes
[Music]
uh first of all we got to know that the
four wives
uh they have
their times yeah everybody have their
time so whatever time
you're in
the you know the you know in islam if
you have four wives you got to equally
divide your time with them
islam is built on justice and fairness
if you got four wives you got to equally
divide your time
among them
and with that being said if you're with
wife number one
so something bad happens you go to her
or or
it's flexible maybe you speak to her and
you say listen i got a problem and i
need to see wife number two because
she's kind of expert in whatever i'm
having so maybe i can go to her and
and then uh
you know like why don't you uh sacrifice
your day for the second wife so i can go
to her now and then we can recon
compensate you with another way and in
another day if you know what i mean
couldn't you gather them all together
well you can do that that's a good idea
actually yeah
i have one wife okay so i don't know
yeah i'm just i'm just curious
that's a good question
it's good to know that if if the
circumstance does arise we have the
tools in our in our toolkit now
okay next question um so given that we
talked about you know roles and
responsibilities but also
compassion mercy love and all that what
are the roles and responsibilities of
men and women in marriage i see a lot of
ridiculous tick tocks and we're not
going to talk about any of the horror
stories that we see from a lot of
brothers and sisters but this you know
are the roles and responsibilities
clear-cut of men and women husband and
wife in an islamic institutional
marriage
all right
the first thing you need to understand
when it comes to marriage
is just like any
company
company means two people okay it's more
than one person getting together it's
just the same concept of any company in
the world whether it's a government
whether it's a company whether it's a
team whether it's it's a nation whether
it's anything you can you can think of
it's not a democracy
you gotta have one captain
you gotta have one
person who puts
decides he has the final say
girls
i'm sorry this is how it is this is how
it's going to work like it or not okay
it's not about being better or or who's
better or who it's just
islam divided responsibilities
you can't have two captains in one ship
the ship's going to sink or it's going
to crash
so you got to have first of all you got
forget don't forget don't forget
islam marriage is built on compassion
built on love built on tolerance built
on mercy
it's not the army it's marriage all
right so that's the first thing you need
to know it's not a democracy there's not
two rulers it's not two rabbi it's not
uh two decision makers one decision
maker however
in islam
it identifies clearly that there is a
distinction between men and women
there's a distinction between husband
and wife
and that's something that's very very
very important today
today they are trying
to the concept of individualism has been
so blown out of proportion and that's
it's been affected even like in in in
marriages
so they say a husband and wife same
thing what do you mean same thing i'll
work she works uh you can sit at home
and raise the kids for the man and she
can go out and work um or or both or
there are no roles in responsibility
this is actually one of the main issues
that a lot of people fall into they
don't know their roles and
responsibilities when it comes to
marriage
the first role and responsibilities
that you need to understand when it
comes to marriage
is something that's very very important
that you need to understand it's
actually it sets out a clear distinction
between the the roles and
responsibilities of husband and wife the
husband it is an obligation on him it is
an obligation on him that he protects
his wife and he provides him with
shelter that's safe whether it's in his
family's home or outside
so that's number one that's not the
husband not on the wife
number two he needs to protect her with
her with his life
if any attacker any harm any kind of
thing that that
that jeopard jeopardizes her life or he
or his children's life
the husband is the first
person who comes and stands up and
defends them
and inshallah is a shaheed because in
another hadith prophet sallallahu alaihi
mentioned that if anybody dies defending
his wife or his family elbow his honor
then he is a child
that's the first thing the second thing
is what
in that ayah means that the husband
spends on her financially
so
you gotta work man you gotta work and
you gotta earn some money
enough money
to afford your living and her living and
your family's living if you're planning
on having kids that's on you allah said
you got to do it not her not shared you
got to do
it what if she's a millionaire
she's i don't know she's just a
millionaire she's really good she has
her own business and she's a millionaire
do you need to spend to her or spend on
her the answer is yes you got to spend
on her
what can she do with her money that's
none of your just none of your business
it's not here it's her money your
obligation as a wife as a husband is
that you support her financially your
obligation as a husband is that you even
give her nasty and you support her
emotionally support her in any kind of
way that she needs and of course the
support is mutual but financially it's
on the husband that's number two number
three
the guy is working hard the guy is
supporting you the guy's defending you
with his life the guy is giving you
nasiha indian and everything like that
you got to obey him
you got to obey him
obey him in what
get outside take off your hijab and
let's go to a club
you don't obey disobedience you don't
obey violation in islam so woman what
you got to do is
your role is that you obey your husband
you protect his home
you protect whatever home he's provided
for you you protect that you protect his
money if he's spending it on you if he's
spending it on the house you got to do
that
and that you obey him
these are the main if you guys do that
husband and wife you guys do that
you're going to be you're going to be
well off
and and you need to know these roles and
responsibilities and to apply these
roles and responsibilities
you need to put between you the husband
and the wife you need to put here in
between you guys the governance of this
this
is religion
because i can't if something happens if
a disagreement happens what do i say is
it my idea is it my opinion or your
opinion it's what happens in the quran
it's what allah dictated to us it's what
the the the the sharia advocated to us
if you apply that the more you apply it
the happier you're going to be
that's how it is
that was such a simple and clear-cut
answer like you you go on islam qa
sometimes you go on all these websites
you go on all these youtubers and this
they panned around the truth sometimes
they want to say what's what what needs
to be said but they don't want to say it
but i'm glad that you gave both sides to
it you gave the nuances you gave the the
shades of grace not so black and white
right it's not like oh a woman just has
to obey her husband uh but it's a woman
does have to obey her husband until it
becomes something haram
and it's not just a man is you know
providing therefore he can yeah but
there's also responsibility he's not
just the captain because he's the
captain he has that responsibility he's
he's held liable he's responsible he's
held accountable he's held to that
standard by allah first and foremost
so uh if both of y'all don't have any
questions i'm going to ask the next one
inshaallah
i have one thing to add yeah
what if what if the husband doesn't
provide what he was supposed to provide
then don't obey him
don't obey him
you have neglected your roles
you don't deserve to be
i don't you don't deserve my obedience
you don't deserve that i listen to you
so a husband like you said it's a great
responsibility and that's why you know
i don't understand people i think
they're crazy people who want to have
more than one wife like are you crazy
you want to have all this
responsibilities on your head
just because of your sexual desires
i don't think it's
i don't think it's worth it and if you
want maybe we can elaborate on on
polygamy
we're gonna we're gonna definitely if we
do a part two it's all gonna be on
pollution and you're done
okay
i don't know what's on your mind i was i
was gonna say man isn't it crazy
that like
this is so simple this is something that
men and women should both understand
intuitively
but in the times that we live in it just
it takes us so far away from this
you know and before i was muslim i used
to watch
movies i used to you know be in these
relationships and
have all the media social media all this
stuff just
bombarding me telling me like what a
relationship is and
and then i had people giving me nausea
advice
they didn't know any better
so i was like they were giving me some
like altered form of what it was and
then it's like i had no idea what i was
doing i was like oh well let me adhere
to this let me try to do this but then
when i stripped it all the way
becoming muslim like i'll be honest i
haven't really done much in terms of
trying to figure out like okay what is
the marriage aspect what is the role of
the the man and the woman it just it
kind of just intuitively understand it
and then what you were saying is well
if a guy
stops to provide
then the woman doesn't need to fulfill
her role
right because he's not fulfilling his
goal but it's like
just think about it if in a relationship
if the man stops providing
the woman will naturally
go to this state where she is not
fulfilling her role she's not respecting
him she's not uh
i'm not gonna say submitting
because a lot of women don't like that
word
but um she's not
she's not being feminine
to him yeah she can't like she you she
can't ease up because the man is not
allowing her to ease up because he's not
doing his part you know what i'm saying
like it it's just crazy how the dynamics
works so
naturally and they're so ingrained into
our feet
that's that's very true that's deep man
yeah
absolutely and
and i've read a lot of psychological
studies about this
that a woman is very attracted to a
responsible man
a man that has responsibilities and
achievements and that's why subhanla you
you watch these uh
you see that a lot women
they get attracted to rich men
men with big cars
it's maybe it's the money but deep down
inside she's looking at him this guy is
successful and he's responsible and he
can provide these two things that i that
that a woman
is intrinsically is looking for
a shelter protection security
and she's looking for for
for uh for somebody to spend on her
it's not haram it's not abe
this is not bad this is what we we are
create this is how we're created this is
a natural thing and a man is looking for
a woman and he's one of the main thing
that he's looking for and sorry to say
this but one of the main things is is
sexual needs
a woman also has sexual needs but a man
is is much much higher and that's why
you see a man is more attracted to these
looks
a beautiful woman
a woman that is sexually attractive
worldwide i'm not talking about what's
halal of course you need to lower your
gaze of course but it's the truth and a
woman when she looks at a man she's not
gonna usually
find sometimes she'll say he's good
looking and all that
but in the end it's how successful how
responsible you are how confident you
are how manly you are you know
and that's what attracts the woman and
just like you said just adding up on
what you said brother
yeah yeah it's it's crazy man because
as men like we have so much things that
we have to fulfill
but it's like again that's it it's
natural it's intuitive and if we just
strip everything away and we do what we
got to do you know if we follow the
guidelines that have been set by us
by allah
it's very simple
it's very simple and it's um
[Music]
very easy to keep a woman in her
feminine it's very easy to keep a woman
you know basically being a woman
absolutely yeah
and like i said
let's not forget a lot of people when
when we say these things they quickly
forget the love compassion and mercy
between these two it's not the army
this is the base all this obedience all
these words that are now they're like oh
did he just did he say that i need to
obey this guy no yeah so what but he
loves you and you love him and you we we
have this beautiful relationship this
romantic relationship together and then
comes the obedience and the the
financial support and all that stuff
and is is like you said was like you
have to have
you you gotta have a lot first you gotta
have decline and so not
first like
it has to be the model because
like this woman this example that you
gave where she's like oh i have to i
have to submit i have to
obey my husband like well why would you
be thinking that way the reason you'd be
thinking that way is because of
something that you were something that
was instilled upon you maybe through
social media maybe to your friends maybe
through the school system your parents
or something like that
absolutely you're right
100 bro because because because men
naturally you know of a creator allah
made no mistake are fitra when it's
intact when it's uncorrupted men are
naturally men and women are naturally
women right but today you see a lot of
uh you know different stuff but before
we get into that this this is a perfect
segue into the next question what are
some of the main issues you see with men
and you know being husbands in a
marriage and with women being wives in a
marriage a good example of this would be
let's say
a man is not providing like you already
said but what would some other ones be
all right so one of one of the things
like you we just talked about
responsibilities you're not providing
responsibility this is a clear violation
is it's a it's a formula or you're
calling for for trouble and maybe even
divorce and not a successful man another
thing is
is is you you gotta understand the woman
bro
guys you gotta understand what a woman
is
a woman is not a man yeah she's human
but she's different
so different like a lot of people they
treat women like guys
and it's
it's calling for trouble
i mean yeah she looks different but
inside she's also different i don't know
this
uh her brain works differently
sorry she has this time of the month
that she gets really aggressive she gets
really sensitive she gets a woman is
more
hearing
you tell her things
it changes her a woman needs to hear
that you love her
she needs to
she needs to hear you that you say i
love you
and she needs a listener she needs
somebody to listen to
speak to
so you you got to sit with her and you
got to speak with her and you got to
tell her that you love you she you love
her
man is different
a man and girls you got to understand a
man
that's why in subhanallah this is very
deep
there's a lot of like jokes on the
internet they say if you want to make a
man is happy make him sandwich
that's that's very deep
or you you know the man's happiness is
in his stomach
yeah that's true that's true because man
is hissy he feels he doesn't hear it
much it's not about hearing
man if you tell him i love you from now
till tomorrow he doesn't care
he wants he wants something to be he
wants
sex he wants people food take care of
the house that's love that's expressing
love for him that makes him happy
and that's true that's psychologically
true that's what man is and a woman is
different she wants someone to hold her
want someone to speak to her she wants
some she wants someone to to to just
tell her that i love you and sometimes
these
men don't and i don't understand it to
be honest
buy her a flower what does a flower do i
don't understand the concept of flowers
because i'm a guy i'm not supposed to
understand what a flower is just buy a
flower and give it to the woman she'll
understand it she'll appreciate it see
what i'm trying to say and by the way
i'm not i'm not perfect in this i need i
need a lot of development in this field
the area too
what what needs to be done is that you
must understand how a woman
interprets or how a woman needs to be
loved
and girls you need to understand how a
man needs to be loved
and this is something that's totally uh
lost nowadays
you don't speak much you don't listen to
her you don't tell her that you love you
baby habibti honey all these words are
very very effective people don't do that
anymore people don't use that anymore
today subhanallah i don't know in the
arab culture they whenever marriage is
mentioned this is very bad really this
is really bad i don't like this discount
attitude in the in arab culture at least
when they talk about marriage oh ho they
always talk about something that's
negative
oh my god do you want to you want to be
trapped in a cage get married you want
to
and
this is
this is because you haven't understood a
woman
this is because you're complaining maybe
because you failed you didn't understand
your wife
and by the way this understanding of of
of what a wife is what a woman is and
what a man is
it doesn't happen
instantly you have to have sabbah you
have to have patience and you have to be
observant and you have to be mindful
so it's going to happen after marriage
maybe a little bit before marriage and
after marriage and it's just going to
keep on maybe after 10 years well i'm
not exaggerating after 10 years of
marriage me and my wife we're still
exploring and discovering new things
about it about ourselves
it's crazy
humans are very complex beings
you can't just expect that i'm living
with this woman and or this man and yeah
i figured him out already no you got to
be sober you gotta have patience you
gotta
patience is is extremely important a lot
of people because of one problem
that's it no that it's not gonna work no
happy
it's a lifetime commitment work hard
fine you're going to cry sometimes
you're not going to like a couple of
things she does the prophet
said this
he said don't hate your wife
if you hate something from her you'll
like something else
so don't judge on one situation don't
judge on one thing
but then the prophet
is telling them
a curved rib what is a curved rib means
means you your brain is like this her
brain is like this it's curved it's
different don't try to fix it she's not
a man
treat her as as she is
so these things people don't understand
are brothers husbands and even the wives
they don't understand these things
and so
women today
they try some women they try to express
their love to their husbands how by
saying i love you honey sweetie buying
him some some flowers no a man doesn't
want that
now you need to do that to her
and same as the as the husband husband
was she was he gonna do he talks to her
about stuff like
tangible stuff
things that are that are very tangible
no i you that's how you need to be loved
not her
that's one thing and another thing
that's kind of sensitive
but your sexual relationship
needs to be
tip-top
this
guys and girls you need to be educated
on this really you need to be a lot of
people i have a lot of friends on court
and they tell me about a lot of divorces
happen
because of because of the sexual
relationship
either it's extreme
one man wants a lot of stuff or stuff
that are impermissible
or it's very low as in dead
so problems happen
sex
intimacy
creates a lot of feelings and emotions
you have to understand this
and it's not something it's natural but
you a woman is a very complex mysterious
being
so you got to be very much just what i
said before you got to be very mindful
you got to be very observant
when you when you're intimate with your
wife
and you have to fulfill her desires just
like you fulfill yours and this is an
obligation
you have to fulfill her desire just like
as you you fulfill yours and you have to
satisfy each other
the prophet
um
it's a bit naive but it's it can be used
or benefited from
the prophet
don't be intimate like you're you're
you're you're an animal
you don't see how animals animals do it
they don't warm up excuse my language
so he said
rasool is the messenger
what does a messenger mean in our modern
way
warm up stop start are you guys married
by the
way no sorry about that
sorry but
i think i think i think uh
is definitely on the way he's engaged
is on the way i believe right okay
that's good so what i'm trying to say is
is sexual education is very good in
halal and i'm not trying to tell you to
watch some crazy stuff but i'm telling
you explore understand that you and your
wife don't be shy
talk about it what do you like what do i
like what's going on what don't you
dislike things like that
and know that
in in in your sexual relationship
the prophet
made it very clear what's happened
and i don't want to get into detail but
from behind
that's number one that we don't do
fee helen if you have curse is a big big
big major sin
second thing if she's in her
in her time period
no
no intimacy anything but the intimacy
the the touching of the two organs
private parts
and nufasa no facade is when she gives
birth that period we call it i don't
know what they're called in english
women and men i think they know what i'm
talking about so these are the
postnatal bleeding
yeah that's the one i think it's like 40
days or so
so these are these are the times that
it's prohibited too
and i have to be clear on this because
it can get a little confusing you have
to understand these things because these
things will create problems well a lot
of a lot of and they have they have this
in you know they have this wrong
uh
idea about about about intimacy they can
do whatever they want and they start
maybe trying to do it from behind or so
and it reaches a woman with you know
it'll create problems and then it'll
reach through a divorce so you'll have
to understand other than that it's
permissible everything i just wanna i
wanna quickly clarify for a lot of the
brothers that that might be a little
confused on that when when uh ahi faris
is saying uh from behind not the
position but the back side
oh god yeah
yeah i was gonna clarify but i was like
i know i don't fight everybody say
something a lot of a lot of guys they
really need to be just
giving it in the most other way possible
bro no they won't understand but you're
right you're right there's another
common issue i see
which is
which is women you know externally
seeking validation overly right they're
they're posting a lot they you know
instagram we see this
where do you think this stems from you
know because we live in a society where
you know anytime you know likes
validation dopamine hits i'm not talking
about the basic you know but i mean do
you see a lot of the time it's linked
from something that's missing in her
life or with her husband
absolutely and i've noticed this by the
way guys
i've seen this at work first of all
i noticed that women
were working women when they stay up
stay up late
i'm not saying it's that's the only
answer but it's an indicator that she
has problems at home
she's running away she's escaping
that's one thing
it can be that
another thing is she's not getting
enough attention from her husband
maybe talking
relationships so you know social life or
maybe even personal intimate life
so she's trying to seek attention
from someone from anyone
so she gets on the the phone and she
starts filming and showing her beauties
and doing this hey guys look at me
i want confirmation i want approval from
someone because this guy is not giving
me any attention
he's not giving me approval not making
me feel like a woman i need somebody to
make me feel like a woman so she's
exploring
and this is what happens
and that's a problem she's fixing a
problem with a problem
but they need to sit down and really
discuss this she needs to express that
listen i need some attention i need this
i need that
and and and they need to fix it so this
is one of the reasons the other other
reason is that
the relationship with allah is not there
so sinning is very easy on men and women
hat men men on tik tok they're on tick
tock they're on all these these social
media tick tock or social or
instagram or whatever any social media i
don't mean anyone in specific but i'm
just talking generally
they're on social media and and they
start looking at things
that are that will make that will
belittle her his wife
sorry but if you're seeing haram you're
seeing half naked women you're seeing
women with filters all the time all the
time what do you expect you're going to
look at yumi like oh my god is that
shrek
but because because
you filled your eyes with all this fake
stuff
no be natural go back to your nature
this is your wife this is your your
beautiful wife appreciate her stop
looking somewhere else why does he do
that again because she's not giving him
the attention maybe she's not being
intimate with him maybe she's not being
looking good for him
and guys after marriage
it's not uh they think like after
marriage like
getting fat and ugly is okay
no it's the opposite
bro you are with your wife respect her
look good for her
and you also look good for him
after you give birth inshallah god
blesses you with a son or a daughter go
hit the gym
do some squats
look at your diet
look good for him he deserves it because
if you don't look at the world
everybody's tempting everyone
it's crazy
so protect your husband and you protect
her
allah azzawajal what did he when he
explained when he said about husband and
wife
he said second
you are second means independency means
somewhere that you go seek refuge to a
shelter
a place where it's it protects you and
spreads that
sequina calms you
down if you're not taking care of
yourself you're not going to calm me
down you're going to drive me away from
you you're not second in lee you're
you're something that i'm trying to
avoid from life
so guys and girls you need to understand
this not because you have you have
obligations or responsibilities at home
or you got a lot of work or you got
children you gotta you're not you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna not take
care of forget yourself don't take care
of yourself
women dye your hair go to the gym
wear some nice clothes men too feel bold
or something just i don't know shave it
and hit the gym you too and drive you
know dress up and look good for her look
good for her that's that's what i'm
trying to say
when you were saying like you know when
men are sinning they're seeing stuff
they shouldn't this reminds me of
something that brother gabriel sent me
the other day it says
he was a scholar of islam he used to say
if i disobey allah i reckon its effects
in the behavior of my wife and the camel
i ride
[Music]
what they say we today we appreciate and
we understand
fixes today's problems
and this disobedience to a light could
be exactly what you're saying seeing
stuff you're not seeing um you know
doing stuff you're not doing even in
private because allah is always watching
and you know it you know from my life
personally speaking i really did see the
effects manifest itself in things you
know relationships with others with
spouse
uh you know
in the camel you're right you know we
don't have camels but it's just in dunya
things you know little circumstantial
things it's very relevant and very
powerful subhanallah but before we go on
rami what's on your mind bro
honestly man i'm just i'm just listening
i had a question before
i was gonna ask it kind of set my mind
now
uh but it was about preparation for
marriage so i don't know if we're at
that stage yet or if we just kind of
like working
up to that point but that's usually the
question everyone has that's the
question i have uh you talked about the
roles the responsibilities and
everything
how do you know you're ready to fulfill
those responsibilities and let's say a
man he's doing you know all he can
let's say he he's out of school he's
working a job and that job is just not
paying enough to provide for you know
him and his wife and his family uh by
himself and because we live in a
two-income society unfortunately would a
man like that just you know not get
married because he can't provide or what
would you say would be the best uh case
for that person
all right can i answer this or you want
to keep it for later there's a big
question
uh
we got about 20-ish minutes left so
okay okay so you got four four sides to
this to this to this dilemma with this
challenge
you got you got the guy
you need to be mentally socially
psychologically and financially prepared
and when i say financially there's
another stakeholder or partner in this
your family
they need to be in on this
if you are young and i will
young guys get married get married
danny this this didn't change young guys
back then what do you think will happen
they didn't have tick tocks or social
medias all this bubbles and all this
this fitting back then and the prophet
used to say get married you need to get
married if you can get married how do
you can financially socially
psychologically all that stuff
i'm financially married uh ready for
marriage
but i don't have much money i'm a bit
struggling with money now comes the
second part the second side or the other
side of of this this equation or the
square
your family i know a lot of guys that
have their family were well off
the guy support the father supported him
his brother supported him on him loan
him get him get married
you you're you're protecting your your
muslim brother your son or your your
brother from falling into major sins
zina
and god knows what happens after zina
you know zina is
is not only
one time thing
it becomes a it it just explodes into
like a chain of sins
don't even come close to it the prophet
said
your hand
your eye the zina your nose the xena
your ear design and all this is approved
by your private part
so
islam is trying to just put you so far
away from zina because it's just
it will destroy uh the umam and you know
in the 80s because of zina and the
spread of zina aids started spreading
so it's not only on yourself but it's it
will destroy everyone really slowly
graduate anyways the first thing is that
the second thing is your family needs to
support you financially and always
that's something that's very sad today
families
they they cringe when they hear their
young sons their daughters they want to
get married what's wrong you're a little
kid no habibi once the guy says i want
to get married take him seriously
that means he's going to he's going to
make a problem or else you please fix
this like protect him from zina
help him out alhamdulillah some families
they're aware of this and they they
support him and they start you know they
look for a good uh candidate for him or
her
and they support her financially because
financially it's something important we
got to face we've got to be admit to
this if you're not financially able
there's a lot of problems that's going
to happen
that's number two number three
the daughter or the the girl
uh you need to find someone that's
that's
that's well prepared that's ready
today
sorry to say a lot of girls
they are mashallah they're 20 even close
to 30 but they act like they're 15.
sorry what's going on here
you need to not man up woman up you need
to woman up you know you're you're a big
girl you're ready now uh gets married
uh so so there's this side of the of the
equation is the woman you need to pick
up a woman or even a partner even the
guy you need to pick up a person that's
that's compatible with you
and how do you find that's compatible
the prophet
said something
um
a wife or a woman is married for four
things
he
these are the four things that women or
men look for
if she's beautiful she got a lot of
money
she she's like from a very well-known
family so he wants some connections or
for her deen for her religion for her
piousness
all the experiences in the world people
have tried beauty and it goes away
people have tried money and it's useless
because one of your obligations is you
need to spend on her that's you're
already violating okay you don't look
for women because of their money people
look for uh tribalism and she's she's
this daughter of this guy and that guy
in a big shot and that just doesn't work
because they'll just make you a small
person an insignificant person because
they're so big and you're so small and
this is going to treat you really badly
but the best thing is that it's because
when you pick a woman that is close to
allah because she knows her rights if
she's close to allah she'll know her
rights
and habibi that's not a problem if you
want to pick a woman that's pious and
beautiful
why that's good imam ahmad even said
that said if you want to pick a woman
you want to pick a wife i don't know why
i keep saying pig it's not a supermarket
if you want to look for a wife
look for beauty and look for religion if
you accept her beauty then go for her
religion
so
it's very good that you that you look
for a wife that's beautiful so that's
number three number four
the family of the daughter
today it's a panel i don't know in arab
cultures
the the the dory or the maha we call it
or the weli they don't support
this this idea of marriage it's very
taboo to them
it's very extreme to them it's very like
weird no they'd rather have their
daughters
get a boyfriend rather than getting
married
it's crazy
and then when a guy comes and he's he's
coming to your door and knocking
respectfully and he's committed and he
wants to uh to build a relationship with
her in in a in a halal way you push him
and you you drive him off or you kick
him off what's wrong with it what's
wrong with your brain are you muslim or
what's going on here
so number four is it's extremely
important and when they ask for a maha
they exaggerate
maybe don't sell your your don't sell
your daughter she's not she's not up for
sale a dory is something or a mahara is
something that you it's a present
given to the to the daughter it's not a
price tag
it's whatever i can give
to the daughter as a gift hadiya why
hadiya why allah azza said or the
prophet
said give them a door so so they become
they become a
that's the beginning the trigger of of
the relationship i'm giving you a gift
money is nice because money is always
valuable in every time and every nation
and everything so when you give money
subhanallah she's happy
she can buy stuff she can she can enjoy
it
and that's the the the beginning of the
relationship for for uh
for a husband and wife and one thing
that's very very important
is that don't build a relationship
before marriage
don't try out it's not a test drive bro
this is a human being with feelings and
it's haram and allah will not bless your
life if you're going to start with a
haram already you're violated
love comes after marriage or when it
becomes serious when it becomes halal
when it becomes you are at another
when you go look at the the
the daughter or the candidate or the
wife and the husband they look and they
sit together and they speak with each
other then slowly slowly this starts
building up
i'm starting to feel for her i'm sorry
to do this for and then there's the
the engagement don't do this and they
have this this weird con misconception
about arranged marriage arrangement they
they think
this is like a what do you call we call
this kinder egg surprise egg here you go
that's your wife
oh no it's not like that we don't this
is actually on islamic you gotta go sit
with your wife you gotta go sit with the
candidate you gotta see her you gotta
speak to her today i see i say that to
to the people to i advise them go and
sit and like interview the girl
and she needs to interview you speak
don't just look at her okay i like her
no habibi sit down with her what do you
like where do you go out what's your
hobbies what have you read all this
stuff is fine sit with her with her with
her wedding or her
talk to her and tell her whatever you
want to want to say
and after that
engagement engagement she's not your
wife she's not your halal and he's not
your halal yet no
sit down meet her respectfully in an
official kind of setting with her maybe
while sit down and speak to her and she
speaks to you get acquainted with each
other and then slowly slowly the
marriage starts happening and after that
you start building what i said at the
beginning the infrastructure love
compassion mercy tolerance all that
stuff people today what do they do
because of because of modernism and all
that crazy stuff we watch on netflix and
all that i want to love i can't i can't
marry someone i can't love what are you
talking about man you've already
violated
you love her now then
then responsibility slaps you right
across the face and you're like wait a
minute i didn't sign up for this i
thought it was just going out for movies
eating pizzas all our life
and that even that starts getting boring
man
like what are you gonna do with your
life really it starts getting boring you
have to understand this guys
marriage goes into phases
it's not it's not rainbows and apples
like all your life no you're gonna have
fights you're gonna sometimes you you're
just gonna like you need some time off
you go out with your friends she goes
out to her family or to her friends
and slowly things build up it gets it
gets normal
it's not it's not rainbows like i said
at the beginning the beginning is nice
that's why they call it
honeymoon it's the honeymoon yeah
inshallah all your life is a honeymoon
but don't expect that the same feelings
are going to stay the same all your life
no things will get will get written
routine kind of thing you know you're
just going to live with this person and
things will change
so people need to be aware of that
inshallah and it's it's not it's not too
difficult to like just just get married
fast the difference between
is
two witnesses and wali that's it
say that again sorry bro the difference
between halal and haram is two witnesses
yeah why are you complicating things
okay okay i'm gonna be your boyfriend
but there's just two guys are going to
stand up there and i'm going to give you
a gift and your wedding's going to be
there
and you're my girlfriend and i'm your
boyfriend in halal
come on what's the issue
um but i'm telling you people
people are worried about
responsibilities people are worried
about commitment
and that's very disrespectful women you
need to wake up
if a guy loves you
and he's
he respects you as a person
not as a sex object and he needs to
commit
never fall for this this trap
may allah our brothers and i know it's a
fit now allah but don't let the shaitaan
trick you not the guy don't let the
shaytan trick you sorry i i refrain from
that the shaytan tricks the guy and the
girl
get to know her blah blah blah it's love
don't worry things will happen and then
they'll start building a relationship
just like just like i said and they
don't want to commit they're worried
about commitment and they do it in haram
they fall for it they start doing things
and then they regret it they regret it
all their lives man especially women and
you know women in society especially
in many societies they don't have mercy
on women
if she is if she's a girl if she's a
girl who had relationships before
you know her reputation they're not
gonna they're not gonna tolerate that
people don't like that
and i'm not telling you that's right
it's haram on the girls haram on the god
but people are like that you're living
in a society you have to you have to
understand how society works so girls be
careful don't fall for these things it's
going to affect you
and guys but girls more i see it
that's the situation that's how it is
and society is ruthless society really
doesn't care about us as much as we you
know people want to think we live in
this matrix and everything's good and
society has the best interest is mine
that's not really the way reality works
there's a bank in in the uh the united
states of america i can't recall the the
bank someone can probably write in the
description that they're they're
basically expecting that about 40 to 60
percent of women from the ages of 18.
sorry not 40 i think it was something
like 70 to 80 of women from uh the ages
of 18 to 40 will be single and
motherless by 2030.
so and and the reason they're they're
coming up with these studies is they're
trying to get investors to see what
market they should invest in
and they're going in in the study on
boxed wine and cat food
so ladies got to realize an entire
market an entire economy is being
invested in is being foresaw right now
on just just seeing where to invest the
money based on you know the marriage
market and that's the reality of the the
state of you know and obviously boxed
wine we don't participate in that is the
kofad but it just goes to show that you
know
this this is the reality this is the
harsh truth the bitter pill to swallow
that it's not you know it's not getting
easier you know we're we're headed
towards uh ignorance
we came out of ignorance but we're
headed towards a time where you know the
righteous are going to be strangers so
you know the time is now use this as uh
as your sign to get married if you were
looking for a sign
and yeah
it's crazy one more thing i just want to
add and
i've noticed that a lot of people they
contact me and a lot of
a lot of the contacts that i get
is is marriage problems
either sister is talking about brother
could you could you help me out
with with i i'm looking to get married
or or a brother
contacts me a sister or brother contacts
me and they just like they were like we
want to get married we don't know how to
or we don't have a candidate or
and then they are they are forced
to to go and go on these applications
and these uh
muslim applications i've i've honestly
never been to it but i don't hear good
things about it
i don't even know their names but they
tell me these names i don't want to
mention them but they tell me like we've
gone to these muslim applications
basically just calling for zina and
haram
so i'm just trying to warn people don't
listen if you're gonna if you're gonna
look for a candidate you're gonna look
for a husband or wife
i think the best approach is that get
connections
with your connections at work a
university a sister you know a brother
you know maybe they have a relative
maybe they have a friend maybe they have
and guys and girls it's not haram to say
i'm looking for a husband or a wife
it's nature it's natural it's natural
stop making stop believing that society
is making it taboo
society is making like oh what are you
saying what you're looking for a husband
how how cheap
oh really but looking for for a
girlfriend and boyfriend is something
that's modern accepted but i'm looking
for something that's halal it's it's
cheap or is degrading or something like
that so people need to get out of that
okay if you're going to look for someone
go and speak up even a woman it's not a
shame
you remove that taboo from society so
what i'm trying to say is is get your
connections and why do i say connections
your mom your brother your sister you're
at work in university because then you
can ask who is this person because you
don't want to you don't want to get
married to a serial killer because a lot
of crazy people out there so that's
that's also a very important thing you
need to have a connection where you can
get information
from this person who is he
what is he like
and that's very very important because
you don't want to commit to a person
that's just you know crazy
yeah and to head to that role i see for
all the men out there
work on yourself
you know and
get on your purpose and all that and get
on to the quran
because if you add that on top of what
the brother here said where it's like
you know you also
verbalize and you tell people like look
i'm looking for a wife inshaallah but
then you're also doing your part was
like you you're filling in all the gaps
and you're letting allah do the rest and
we had a guest a while back uh
alidawah good brother good brother masha
allah and he had mentioned that like
for him when he was trying to get
married he was having all these issues
all these problems
and it wasn't until he realized like oh
there are some things that i have to get
right
with allah some things that i'm not
doing right
and then when he fixed that it's as if
like this carpet was rolled out for him
subhanallah and and think about what we
were talking about the um
was it hadith
what the thing about like oh if you
if you aren't like
doing everything properly with allah
then you can notice it in your woman
it's a narration by a scholar of the
team
so look at that right before the man
even gets into marriage
before he gets into marriage
this is already presenting itself to him
so if he can tackle that right now if he
can fill in the gaps then he's essential
he's essentially preparing himself
for a proper marriage
you know and i don't know i just it's
it's cool because it's like everything
just connects together here absolutely
it's it's just like the concept of
building up your cv
guys build up your stevie make us
something that you're proud of so when
people ask about you it's good brother i
i recommend him for you and women will
come running after you and you also
sister
build up your cv get close to allah take
care of yourself have that good
reputation among the sisters among your
community and people come running after
you
for halal
all right what a wonderful note to end
it on and uh for our brothers and
sisters uh mashallah that are inspired
by you know and are moved by what you
said today and they want to follow more
of your work what platforms are you on
i'm on tick tock uh and i'm on instagram
inshallah i'm very lightly on but i
share whatever video i share i put it on
youtube sometimes but tiktok on
instagram these are the two most active
uh platforms inshallah i'll just put the
links in the description for uh you know
top of the description for anyone that
wants to follow brother faris or if you
don't want to follow i highly recommend
you follow him and uh you know your life
might uh insha allah be a little bit
better by his reminders that i see every
day on tik tok and
foreign
you got a patreon if you guys don't know
what patreon is it's a site where we
post exclusive content that never airs
on youtube and we also post content
early that does there on youtube
if you like the content that we're
putting out here
you want that more in-depth
contact more
personal more real
stuff that we can't put on youtube
then go ahead and head over to our
patreon
it's pretty much free if you think about
it
the lowest here is five dollars
break that up between what 30 days
how much is that
that's 15 cents a day
guys
come on we're not trying to gain
anything really from this it goes the
masjid fund we also give to sadika we
get to charity and
if we truly need a little bit for our
bills or just something
or means for food or
something along those lines that's what
we might use it but for the most part
like this is
this is all for the sake of allah here
so whatever you pay allah is going to
give you back
and then so we've been making free
content and it does take a lot of work
like people don't realize how how much
work it takes to sometimes do daily
uploads a new video every day it does
take a lot of work so essentially you
guys do help support the channel help
keep us going help us
propagating the dean of allah when we
record patreon videos like patreon
videos are when the the realest of the
real in us come out
because we're not thinking about like
all this gonna go on youtube i can say
this word i can't say that word
we are as clear-cut as specific as
unfiltered as we need to be you know as
muslims as we should be alhamdulillah
very straight to the point and you'll
see like videos with with me and and
fired and angel they're just so real on
patreon and i think that's what the
muslim um needs and if you need you know
real brothers that are willing to have
real conversations with you
hit that patreon up because if you guys
think that our channel is real
and you talk about youtube then just
imagine what patreon could do for you
inshallah instead of becoming a member
link in the description take your life
to the next level insha allah and we'll
see you on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]